good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us today both uh in person and
online
I hope I do hope that you and your
families are safe after the wild weather
that we head
uh last night
as I've mentioned in previous meetings
we'll be alternating between a karakia
and a English prayer at the beginning
and the end of the meeting last month we
started with the katakia so today I will
start with an English prayer and Nikki a
GM of people and culture will close us
out with a cut a Kia
Lord in heaven we come before you
offering our thanks for bringing us
together safely sometimes it is easy to
forget that our safe arrival and
departure is Grace from you as we
prepare for this meeting we ask that you
would be with us today
May our thoughts be led by you our
conversation inspired by you help us put
our own agendas to the side and seek
your will and outcome for this meeting
please grant us wisdom and Times of
uncertainty and Clarity in times of
confusion lead us to Solutions and help
us strengthen as a group in Jesus name
amen please be pleased oh
thank you
so we have any apologies today
we'll look present and accounted for
no apologies
uh Declarations of conflict of interests
none
minutes of previous meeting so first up
is the confirmation of the minutes of
the ordinary meeting of the gore
District Council held on Tuesday the
14th of February
did we have any questions for the
government's support on these minutes
can I please have a mover that these
minutes are true and correct
uh councilor Dixon and a seconder
counselor Paul mcphail
all those in favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
next up we have confirmation of the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
the Gorda Street Council held on Tuesday
the 21st of February 2023
do we have any questions for governance
on
these minutes
could I please have a move that these
are true and correct
councilor Richard mcphail seconder
councilor John Garden
all those in favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the orderton risk committee
held on Tuesday the 21st of February
let's make sure there are minutes here
anything for that one
uh did anyone have any questions for
governance support on that those minutes
no could I please have a mover that
these are true and correct
councilor bronman Reed and a seconder
councilor Dixon
I will put the motion all
was there a discussion point there
counselor
am I pretty
much oh yes you are you are correct
sorry
could I have a secondary who was on the
committee
councilor Garden
there's the second to there
all right we'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
confirmation of the minutes of the
community well-being committee held on
Tuesday the 21st of February 2023
the only
recommendations I just like to bring to
the attention of council uh was the
recommendation that the council approved
financial assistance in the sum of 800
to enable Gore country music Queen to
attend the Tamworth Country Music
Festival that have been held in January
that was recommended by the committee I
was just alluding to it to see if there
were any objections if not
oh that was the only one I noticed of
note maybe of contention
it doesn't look like there's an issue
around the table which is cool
could I please have a mover that was on
that committee that that those months
are trying correct councilor Phillips
and a seconder counselor Robin Reed
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
just come to the realization that I said
that these minutes are true and correct
whereas I should be saying to also
rectify the recommendations in this were
there any complaints about that I
wouldn't imagine so
no that's cool okay I will make sure I
put my word incorrectly for these next
ones uh the confirmation of minutes of
the meeting uh the infrastructure
committee held on Tuesday 7th of March
so the only one uh that's
we won't be ratifying uh as Point number
three um as there is a later agenda
minum
I think that was the only one and then
that is
so other than uh Point number three
could I please have a mover that these
are true and correct and to ratify all
of the other recommendations bar Point
number three uh councilor heisted
seconded by councilor John Garden I will
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
and against the motion is carried
lucky last uh confirmation of minutes of
the policy and planning committee held
on Tuesday 7th March 2023
uh the only point I will bring the
council's attention to is just um Point
number two there that the recommendation
was to change the name of the committee
so those who are not on the committee um
just be aware that if this is to be
moved that that will change names um so
not to get confused
do we have any questions of those
minutes uh councilor Phillips
thank you just that I was actually
entertaining to that meeting my name's
normally
thank you
thank you counselor that's been noted
any further comments questions concerns
nope could I please have a mover that
there's a true and correct and to ratify
those recommendations uh councilor hovel
seconded by councilor Stuart McDonald
uh we'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
like business uh so I do have one item
um
to be added this will be an in committee
item
it is the James [__] Community Center
Library an opening gesture so I will
was there any other urgent business
nope I will move the motion
um to add that to the in committee
agenda could I have a seconder
councilor Stringer I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried sorry
I should describe to the public why that
has been added as an urgent item it has
been added because the library will be
opening on Friday and that item will be
relevant to the opening as it is a
opening gesture so it needs to be
discussed at this council meeting and
can't be rolled over to the next
getting into the media that now we have
the Hilby Avenue Water Tower structural
Integrity upgrade
did the report ricer have any further
comment
through your worship thank you
um this report's provided to the council
following the recommendation of the
assets and infrastructure committee to
defer the demolition
of the hillbury Avenue Water Tower until
2024-25 to undertake additional
de-sledging works at the gore Wastewater
oxidation ponds the committee was
concerned about the risks of delaying
the demolition of the hillbry Tower and
as such this report outlines previous
structural assessment reports undertaken
by by Becker over the past 18 months
around that structure
with myself and uh asset manager Amit
Bellas are here answering questions from
the council thank you
thank you for that Jason uh did we have
any questions for the report writer
councilor Dixon
you worship
and the removal of any loose sections of
concrete
that through you worship staff are
required to be on site
um on a reasonably regular basis with
this still being um activity on there
however that's not within the uh
exclusion zone is outlined in the report
so during that time uh we are checking
the structure for
um
any obvious
issues relating to wear and tear but
thank you
Council hosted
you thanks Mr me just through you to um
to the manager I guess the decision to
demolish was based on the health and
safety concerns and um
I see there are intended mitigation
measures to be put in place I guess time
frame would be useful to understand and
also one of the one of the areas
identified was ability for the public to
access despite the being a gave in place
so just like to understand
you know when and what will happen to
satisfy the health and safety concerns
there
through your worship uh so those
mitigation measures outlined in the
report um have been undertaken this
point so they are the site is restricted
um so you can't public can't access that
um and the exclusion zone is in place I
guess the question for the the council
was whether
um the current uh mitigation measures
um
provide enough
to ease those concerns raised at that um
at that committee meeting or whether
they think staff need to undertake
further
um
I guess further mitigation measures to
offset those but at this point staff
believe there's enough mitigation in
place to avoid
um health and safety issues
just coming on the access gate would be
useful
okay
it's really worship
um yeah so the gate is permanently
locked now
um and so that was changed
um or probably approximately two years
ago when we upgraded
um the perimeter fencing and yeah
implemented a policy where the gate is
always locked unless some of the staff
are on site
Council husted
councilor Stringer
let's throw his worship
um what buildings if any or any services
on the property of the air are still
utilized or used by the council
through your worship
um so at the site there is
um a water treatment plant and a
reservoir which is still functioning
obviously the plan is to decommission
the treatment plant once we get a
pipeline across the Matera River
and the reservoir is up for renewal
um once that pipeline is installed as
well
the other main building is obviously the
water tower
um which we're obviously discussing now
and there's also a small uh building
where a generator is housed although
that building is going to be
replaced by the new pumps pump shed um
that we're proposing as part of this
work
cancel mcfarl
I think you worship I'm just looking at
gate again sorry I'm just
um is it defending right round
high defensing right around or is it
through your worship
um there's sections of of deer fencing
um
and then there's
sections where an existing
fence has been extended to the to a
height of of deer fencing
um
and then on the side where there's
Residential Properties there's
um
like a more standard boundary fence
that's approximately 1.8 meters high as
well
okay I'm just looking at the picture
here and maybe I'm on a cancer looks
like there's a gap between the trees and
the fence but is that correct
the entrance free worship no I believe
the fence goes around behind those trees
that you're looking at no that's fine
then thank you
councilor Richmond Val
it's just true you worship it baby uh
Neil or Matt will be able to answer just
in regard to what you've been doing up
there have you talked to any of the
local residents around any activity or
anything that actually happens around
there is there anything that of concern
um I believe obviously if you've given
us the assurity believe you have
security there we have to take that on
on the fact that that you have the
expertise to do that but is there
anything that actually is people coming
and going and see some tagging on the
side and
um various things there's no other Intel
or information we need to know about
so you worship certainly prior to us
upgrading the fence and permanently
locking the gate there was certainly um
reports of of community members going
into the site I'm certainly not aware of
any since we've upgraded the fencing
um and made it a bit more secure
in terms of communication with
neighboring Property Owners so we did
um
talk to a number of the neighboring
property owners and and did a letter
drop to the ones that weren't home when
we got the structural assessment
completed just to let them know what was
happening with that
um and then if there is a need to talk
to neighboring property owners and we're
doing that on a case-by-case basis for
the work that we're doing at the moment
thank you for that Matt thanks for that
counselor uh any further questions for
staff
uh councilor Havel
am
sorry the first recommendation that the
report be received
uh yeah that's absolutely fine you'd
like to move that
um kind of secondary
uh councilor McDonald and I will open
the floor for debate uh councilor Hotel
would you like to no
uh councilor Stringer
oh you look I'd just like to put this
out there for um
everyone's perspective
um so I've seen the figure somewhere
it's it's made 450 000 for removal of or
demolition of guitar
um
do we have any reason for
holding the land afterwards or is that
something we could survey off and sell
the tear
because it according to the figures here
it's yes it's below the 67 National
Building standards International
building standard but the report says
that there's only suffering cosmetic
spalling other than that it's
structurally sound
if someone wants to turn it into an
Airbnb or a bungee jump platform or
something like that
um as best we sell it and pay down some
debt we'll use that money for extra
de-sludging than spending almost half a
million dollars and it probably will be
half a million dollars in years time to
demolish it
just putting it out there
to through your worship
um so
this is a couple of things there
um
so as part of the reservoir replacement
project
um we've done the concept design work
for that and
the plan is to initially install one new
Reservoir at the I guess Northern end of
the site away from the water tower
but also there's going to be provision
for a second future Reservoir
closer down to the water tower
um
but
um existing and
existing Access Road into that site goes
right next to the to the water tower and
a little bit difficult to provide a
alternative access
um
if you were to sell off a section with
the water tower
and I guess going back to step the
recommendation around the water tower
demolition was really around
the the recommendations that that Becca
made around an ongoing maintenance
program of the water tower with the
expectation that as as that
structure continues to age over time
you'd expect the the stripes show and
integrity and the current issues to
become worse
um that maintenance program was going to
have
um
I'd expect reasonable ongoing costs
associated with it
and given there's there's no real use
for the water tower going forward
um that the best thing to do was was to
demolish it and avoid those ongoing
maintenance costs
yeah
Council Hotel
there is a motion on the table that the
report be received and if we can deal
with that first and then the second
matter that I wish to do as a separate
motion
I was opening the floor to debate after
the so we could further talk about the
report
so if there are a few other things to be
discussed about the report before we
receive it and then we can start to more
recommendations might pop out of that as
is my thinking behind it sorry councilor
were there any further cushions around
the report councilor Phillips
I think you worship just um I I like um
Joe's way of thinking but I think the
complications of
physically the parts on the ground and
Etc that are that are there um
would probably inhibit the
the selling of that structural land
without an easement
and I know there's a couple of pipes
that run through properties already so
yeah it will be difficult I feel
were there any further questions around
the report or the
that idea that Council Stringer has
brought to the table
nope I'll put the motion uh that's the
report be received or those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried uh the
second recommendation on the table is
that the council agreed to yeah sorry
if I could not be interrupted please
counselor
um that the the second recommendation on
the table is that the council agreed to
defer the demolition of the Hilbert
Avenue Tower until the 2024 Financial
year before I asked for a mover and a
secondary I will open the floor for
debate Council have
I was trying to avoid
um
a little bit of time by actually
suggesting an amendment to that motion
as the initial motion I now can't do
that until it's moved and seconded
I didn't put I didn't put the
recommendation I was just reading it out
for clarification so you can make the
you can make the amended go for it all
right I I'd like to move the motion that
the council agreed to defer
consideration of the demolition of the
hillbury Avenue Water Tower until the
2023-24 annual plan process
would you like to move that
recommendation yes
uh do we have a second day
counselor McDonnell uh and now open the
floor for debate
so the recommendation is that we deal
with this annual plan not the 2024 2025
Financial year however we would be doing
an annual plan for
that's right I'll let you speak Council
thank you the the key word that I've put
in there is consideration the way that
the initial recommendation was worded
that we deferred demolition on wanting
to actually defer the decision on
whether we demolish until the annual
plan process and and I made reference to
the 2023 sorry 20 23 24
um plan process but if it makes more
sense for 20 24 25 I'm quite happy but
as I said the key is the way that's
worded where I believe we're committing
to demolish it is part of that year
whereas we should be making a balanced
decision on whether it is demolished in
the timing of it at a later date
do we have any further discussion on
that recommendation
councilor Garden
yeah I'd agree that we do defer making a
decision to a later date because there's
some other
um decisions to be made before that
and they could um change their thinking
thank you
Council electric file
yeah just um it's a bit like watching a
tennis match at the moment so I'll sort
of run step in the middle
um
I agree yeah defer and obviously I
brought up the fact around
um the health and safety issue and the
enlightenment that we actually have
around that demolition
process here we have got an aging
structure I'm satisfied that some of the
concerns I had have been addressed in
relation to provision of um in a solid
belief by Council staff that we can we
can hold that through so I'm quite happy
to
um to put my support behind that motion
currently
on the on the uh basis that we do do due
diligence around ensuring the property
doesn't end up in a situation where we
fall into health and safety issues that
we don't let it go
thank you for that councilor well part
um I think as it stands
um
just just the clarification this does
mean that staff can go ahead and invest
that money into the extra Des lodging
um and that we will revisit the tower
issue come annual plan to see whether
demolition given
um that councils seem comfortable with
the health and safety Provisions that
have been taken whether that demolition
does need to occur in the next annual
plan
do we have any further discussion
that I believe it was the 23 24
yep
so that that will be in the the coming
few coming months we will have the
discussion about whether it needs to be
put in that annual annual plan
now for the discussion I will put the
motion uh all those in favor please say
aye
and against the motion has been carried
it's okay
next up recycling so rethinking waste do
we have a further comment from the
report writer
uh through your worship thank you very
much
um
uh the rethinking waste update report
um identifies options for Council to
consider prior to community consultation
I would just like to introduce uh two
councilors to my left uh Dr Nikki bold
Nikki has been is one of the countries
leading experts in sustainability and
Waste Recovery Nikki's been part of
council's rethinking waste projects
since early last year
um and is here to support the options
report prepared by ahika Consulting
attached to this report
um
I just want to I guess note as
highlighted in the report that the
reintroduction of recycling is only one
part of the council's waste overall
waste Journey
um
there's certainly still significant
education awareness promotion Community
interaction in monitoring required to
meaningfully reduce the amount of waste
going to landfill providing the the
infrastructure to help support that's
only one part of it
um but this is uh
considered to be the first step of of
many the council needs to undertake to
reduce the amount of waste
produced by the gore District that's
going to landfill and how we can better
repurpose reuse and recycle that so uh
Nikki and I are happy to
um take any questions from Council thank
you
thank you for that Jason and yes welcome
Nikki um thanks for coming out here
today in this weather it's fantastic to
have you here in person and uh thank you
very much for the report it's uh very
insightful
I'd like to open now for any questions
for the report writer and also open it
to Nikki as well because she is part of
that report
I will kick it off with some questions
uh Jason to meet the proposed date of uh
July 1st 2023 if we were to go with a
three bin option when would the bins
need to be purchased
to get here by that date
now three worship my understanding that
there's a potentially two to three month
um
order period to get the bins
constructed and then delivered to uh
invercargill
um through our contractors and then have
them
into Gore and then out to properties so
um the the timeline to meet uh one July
um is probably too tight because I think
we need to be ensuring that we undertake
the consultation process
um necessary so that we get the
appropriate feedback from our community
on which option they would prefer to go
with so
thank you for that Jason
um I had a question here two questions
here for Nikki the first one
um is around organic waste looking at
these options and excuse my ignorance on
this one they're quite expensive
um what's the I guess the difference
between these these options and like the
60 compost bin which would be
significantly easier for councils to
help fund
that's why we put one of the options as
home composting because with a lot of
education and help we could reduce
organic Center landfill with the home
composting option but research is
showing that actually having
um green waste in particular picked up
at the curbside is
um being it's way more successful
because you actually you're providing a
solution for
um households that don't have the space
to be able to compost their
um their green waste and also uh shove
it in there if they don't have the
ability to put it in a trailer and drive
it down and get rid of it for free then
having it collected at the curbside for
green waste and then having the option
for the food waste in there as well is
proving around the country to be
successful that's why it's in there but
we're also talking about
because Gore is small we need a
feasibility study to actually understand
whether it's worth it or whether it's
actually just a better option to push
that home composting option so that's
right there and it is thank you for
bringing up the organic speakers
Organics is really essential to get out
of landfill
thank you for Nikki that's um
yeah let's get insightful uh the only
other question I had just for
clarification
um in the appendices 6.1 it shows here
that 65 out of 67 councils are doing
things like paper and cardboard steel
and aluminum Etc are we one of those two
who are not
yes thank you for that clarification so
that's um
yeah pretty pretty shocking that we're
one of two in the country
uh let's start with Council Stringer
uh through his worship
um
4.2 uh the levy rate that has obviously
set on the waist
um that Levy do the councils have access
to that in any respects to starting the
Iran recycling or using them recycling
purposes like for funding those bins
okay first if you want to eat anything
through your worship the um
the waste Levy that we pay
for
um waste games landfill councils do get
back a portion of that it's a very small
portion currently uh I think in The
Current financial year we've got about
about 60 000 to
help
help undertake activities that divert
waste from landfills such as recycling
um but the this is scheduled well this
is outlined to increase as the waste
living increases but
um
for again for a small account so we are
proportion or share is relatively small
however part of that funding from the
waste Levy also goes to things like the
waste minimization fund which councils
can apply to to undertake projects such
as feasibility studies around organic
waste in other other potential options
to
minimize waste in the district
worship it's probably um more of a
statement and there's another old
Council would say let me indulge myself
we've actually looked at obviously the
weight waste of minimalization and
firstly Nikki I appreciate the work
you've done on there you've done for the
last few years and uh it's really good
but we sit here today bashing this
around in the last two days we've seen a
government that's stepped back from its
model return scheme and our little Old
Town like Gore and it's a small council
is still working away at that I'm
interested to see what Nicki's views or
what she believes in relation to I know
we talked about it during some of the
workshops that government would be
looking at us and um putting some
central government would be putting
pressure on and then they step back from
these schemes which obviously would
address some of our problems with
containers that are going into our
rubbishtons on the street side
I'd be just interested in her opinion
well um I think out of all of the
um
the things that they could have stepped
back on it doesn't bother me too much
about the council uh the container
return scheme because to be perfectly
honest we've got to get methane out of
landfills and that's organic waste so if
they're going to have to prioritize and
they're deciding that
um Plastics isn't as important then yeah
it's a step in the wrong direction but
they haven't yet pulled the work that's
going on in Organics so I'm
I'm of the belief they're not going to
pull that climate change is real and
methane being emitted is real and that's
an issue
um the the Plastics the container return
scheme would have stopped plastic
pollution ending up in our oceans that's
one of the um the big benefits of it I
think
I don't have a crystal ball I don't know
what's going to happen I really don't
want them to back down on any more
climate change
decisions so in my opinion for Gore is
be leaders take some take a chance and
go push this boat out as far as you can
is my opinion
uh Council Reed thank you Mr
um a couple of questions
um probably directed more at Jason
um
before we go out to consultation it
would be really good if we had some
figures so that people could know how
this is going to impact on rates and I
guess one of the things that I wonder
about is the cost of new bin
and what impact that would have that's
my first question
three worship
um
one of the I guess one of the challenges
with this process is that the costs are
hard to um
they had to forecast because it's around
how much
was going to be recycled so a cost based
on per ton and so we've got
even looking back at the previous models
where we
um we had glass as part of that glass is
obviously really heavy so trying to
forecast what the rate impacts will be
as a challenge it's not impossible
what we've one of sort of how
highlighted in the report
um
is that I think there's within the
current recycling budget
um we can meet those costs for this
first year
um
what has been happening though is that
the Overflow from the waste expenditure
cost though has been offset by recycling
costs and that that is something that we
do need to address and we we the report
is really estimating there
um the shortfall
um I believe that your current budget
for Waste disposals just over 1.2
million and where our actual spend is
1.7 million so there's about a 500 000
shortfall there so that's a that's a
challenge that we have to work through
through their annual plan process which
is again why I think this is
um there's some benefit and not rushing
to meet a one July
date whereas we if we can through this
annual plan process line everything up
and make sure that we we understand the
full impact because it's not again
trying to look at something in isolation
we're trying to try and look at these
things together to understand what the
impact for rates is
um there's certainly an impact there the
other thing we can look at too around
that process is the fees and charges
schedule you know so we could look at
the cost of disposing of waste to our
transfer station looking to up those
costs in line with the waste Levy to try
and offset some of the rate impacts as
well so staff are working through those
currently in terms of our proposed
budgets for the annual plan and that
will all sort of feed into the overall
picture of about a rate impact
thank you
um but probably didn't answer my
question my question was the price of
bins to be supplied to households
yes so okay just add to answer that
question uh the the price of bins
effectively works out an additional bins
about 50
just over fifty dollars per household
what we would look to do again is um
Loan Fund that so that those costs are
spread out and just reduce the the
immediate impact of that capital
expenditure and trying again trying to
again keep it within that existing
recycling budget that we have so
um there would be the proposal was to do
that and then understand what our
additional
um recycling processing costs are as we
move through into a long-term plan
process
the other thing sorry hold on I'll come
back to you um
given that there is a big cost to us and
we are a small Council and I know we've
come down the last couple of years with
working alongside Mickey to get these
um ideas and um reports that we've
received but I mean is it not time to
stop and think that we might be better
to be looking across the district and
working in with like for instance South
and District Council it's an expensive
cost to recycle I realize that I know we
have to recycle but we have to recycle
smarter and I think smarter might be
looking at working with existing
councils I know that Dunedin and Nikki
who may be able to help you has a an
ability now to recycle Organics
was that correct it's not
it's not sorry it's not up and running
yet but they are moving towards the
forbin system yeah yeah I just think it
would be another I don't know how we go
about it but maybe it's a given that we
have a regional climate strategy that's
worked in with those other three
councils can we not look at that for
recycling I'm not talking about going
back through waste net or that sort of
thing but but maybe just a problem cost
efficiency and all of them just some of
those things that could be done as a
whole region particularly around organic
waste and also of course the education
side of it that because that's everybody
just takes it for granted if it goes in
the red bin it goes to landfill so
but I'd be very keen to see us see what
the other councils are doing in the
region
through your worship or just just to add
to that that I think it's no surprise or
it's not a news to anyone that the
momentum I'm wasting it over the past
couple of years has slowed however
certainly at a staff level we've been
pushing that the um the governance group
for Waste net is due to
um
finally reconvene in the coming weeks
and certainly I think that should be one
of the discussions at a political level
put on the table around
um you know sort of this future proofing
really working together because we do
actually have an advantage through
having that
collaboration across both SDC and ICC so
there's certainly are opportunities to
re-establish some of the momentum that
has dropped away with with wastenet so
there's certainly uh something on the
radar
so I just want to say a follow-up
question and then we've got Council
Dixon then councilor mcphail
um just to that point there is a wasting
it as a collaboration between ourselves
and the cargo and uh Southland um but
like Jason said it has lost momentum so
there is a lot of work being done to get
that momentum going but it is it is slow
going so we're kind of somewhat on our
own at the moment but but that will come
to fruition I just had a follow-up
question around the bins um we were
talking about that Levy before is it
potential to get grants to help pay
subsidize those those bins
it and the short answer is yes uh
however we are there's
a Plastics fund that we can we can apply
to again
um that will take some time to work
through that once we understand what
option uh councils are going to go
through
um but we can't we can do that but we
are a little bit behind in terms of some
of the um that funding that has been
applied to other areas
like to answer that the um the fund was
open a few years ago for recycling in
particular to be able to fund bins but
that's now moved into Organics so now
the focus for the ministry for
environment is to get Organics out and
that's where the money lies so if you
were to go down the option four which is
looking for feasibility study you could
get support for that and then if you
moved into implementation you can get
support for that but as Jason says the
recycling bins is a little trickier to
get support for now
I think it's that Council Dixon
thank you worship
um I think it's great to see Gore taking
some leadership on this waste issue I
just have a question for Nikki I have
heard that a b line are looking for more
organic waste because they're creating
methane
um over there for to run some
electricity
facilities that they have
if she perhaps a chance that they could
pick up air organic waste if they if
they needed more waste there's one
question I have another but I'll let you
answer that one
to be perfectly honest I couldn't speak
on behalf of a b lime but it is in
direct contradiction to what MFE is
trying to do which is reduce methane at
landfill level I would need to look into
what they're actually how they're doing
it because if they are
running a organic processing facility
and capturing it from there so if
they're doing biogas absolutely they
would be perfectly situated to be the
basis for something like this but I I
don't know I'm sorry okay no that's fine
the other I just think there is no real
incentive for people to reduce their
waste and but the only one that I can
see here is reducing the size of the
bins to 140 liters from 240.
I think then people might start thinking
well they're overflowing their bins and
they might like to reduce their waste
otherwise and the other thing that it
did concern me was for elderly who we're
giving them extra bins but half the time
a lot of them don't even fill one in two
or three weeks with their rubbish and
they probably have very little organic
waste as well I I'm just not sure how we
would go about about doing that
could I answer was that a question can I
answer because
sorry
there's um so what what you're saying
there with the reduction in size of the
actual wheelie bin from 240 down to
um 140.
um that has proven to work around the
country to reduce waste to landfill and
because you're right if it's a bigger
bin people just Jam more into it you
give them a smaller bin it definitely
makes them stop and think if they have a
selection they have to then think okay
I've got to separator into the right
place so that does work in terms of
Organics it could be that you have an
opt out
system so that if you are already at
home composting you could potentially
opt out of that bin but that would be
something you'd need to look into to
figure out the feasibility of it and and
what that might look like but you you
write there's probably some people who
are doing a great job already
customer care
thank you worship um just another thing
I've just thought of two things yeah
there's the supermarkets in town or any
in an area they must have masses of
organic waste being thrown out all the
time how does that come through have you
looked at that in the studies to see
what effect that has
um we're looking at curbside collection
rather than
um business there's a there is a fund
there specifically to address business
food waste and I can tell you now that I
don't know what happens in Gore but in
Dunedin for example we have the likes of
kiwi Harvest that work very closely with
big organizations to rescue edible food
that before it becomes waste I would
like to think that that potentially
happens here but I I don't know if
there's any organizations or groups like
that I might have to ask Jason does it
go to a a landfill now the anybody know
oh sorry
through your worship
um both supermarkets and the I can't
speak for the last three years but prior
to that all uh produce waste Deli waste
Etc went to apart from Meats went to
local pig breeders
so the meat said to be separated out and
I'm just put into General refuse
Council Stringer
cushion through his worship to Jason
the current Organics that people do drop
off at the tap or
is it able to be either composted beer
or does it go into the gore gardening
compost scheme to reduce
what we need there on a
services
through your worship for the green waste
that gets deposited there does get
semi-composted and is being used for
coverage
we separated that after a certain point
but it's not of any quality that could
be be used around the um
the town and the garden situation
because people still throw a lot of
rubbish out so they can save save a
dollar
amongst the green waste
so councilor Paul mcphail did you have
any further comments sorry I don't mean
to cut you off there
but you wish it um just the other thing
the the consideration of a waste
management person I think that another
councils had does that help with the
process that we're talking about and how
is there is there a recommend have you
seen a percentage drop off or does it
affect that
I couldn't give you a percentage drop
off but I can tell you that the councils
that have waste minimization staff would
be able to also address the question you
had regarding the supermarkets around
because your staff member would be able
to run educational campaigns work with
schools work with the likes of the big
businesses cafes all of those people and
actually get that education level up
um could be that that person could help
establish a community organization using
some of the waste minimization fund and
offer some funding support to help get
something like that up and running so
having a dedicated person to this is
is essential in my opinion
uh I'll let you speak in a second
councilor um I'm just gonna one more
question and then we'll open up the
debate just to keep the keep things
rolling counselor
I live in a rural area and every two
weeks a commercial person comes along
and picks up my green bins and tips it
in the back of their truck and takes it
down to the tip
um I'm just wondering whether the though
for those people outside of the service
area is the volume of waste that has
generated significant to the extent of
something we need to be looking at
yes yes it does I mean it does
contribute to that I think in Dr Ball's
report it outlines the percentages of
um
the amount of waste that goes from
residential and other waste which
includes our rural areas so in terms of
that that's what I mean about the fact
that there's a lot more that needs to be
done we are starting to see
um
businesses start to look at the rural
areas so we have seen with a company out
of Pokhara to start servicing rural
areas around a number of different
options and looking to expand that so
um again this is where we need we needed
the ability to work on this
um and give it the
um the focus that it needs to be able to
put
the right people in touch with the right
people and make the impact that we need
to have in terms of of reducing waste so
um no I think that is still part of it
Council novel
uh I'm I'm gonna sorry cancel the
follow-ups I'm gonna open It Up For
Debate now so it's not just questions
it's jumping into to the debate
um I just
gonna do one of my lovely speeches that
I know Richard mcfarl loves so much
um but I I think it's it's clear in this
report that there are basically three
options on the table
um the which when you break it down the
the three options are fundamentally here
today the same to the ratepayer in my
opinion option one and two are simply
unacceptable
um it's clear that we can't stick to the
way things are now it's not sustainable
um and like is outlined in the report if
we go back to the way it was in 2020
ultimately we're taking a step backwards
so so realistically
um this leaves us with with points three
four and five as points one and two
would not only do a disservice to the
right power but ultimately a disservice
to our planet
so that leaves options three four and
five and the bottom line for all of
these options that it's a three three
bin system
and potentially looking into a fourth
whether that's home Organics or or
curbside pickup for Organics but but
fundamentally those those three bins
which is landfill uh Recycling and then
glass
um are your primary options
and I'm a firm believer that we need to
give staff direction to execute uh
recycling by first of July as put out in
this report I will now open up for
debate did you want first goal at
councilor Phillips
thank you worship
um or my Debaters is that if we keep
giving people the bins to put the
rubbish in they're going to keep putting
it in
you know like I I agree with Nikki's
um when she said about the organic bin
that perhaps then that we have an
incentive is that if we give you a room
in space in availability in education on
how to create your own organic
bin then instead of giving them a bin to
put on the curbside we give them a bin
to put in their Garden
you know and to me that's more feasible
way of spending money because you're not
going to do that bin for a start off
so that was just my opinion on on that
on that issue you know I don't believe
that we should be keep giving the the
residence bins and I don't have any bins
at my place and I know the cost of
traveling to the transfer station do
put over my rubbish and I'm very
conscious of what I put over it because
it cost me
hmm
thank you for that counselor
do we have any further opinions on the
recommendations Council Heist here
yeah the slide to figure out and the
question that the councilor Reid raised
and that's the question of cost and
that's the only question I've had from
the community since this is reports
being socialized people need to
understand what it costs we know that
recycling is recycling is expensive and
we have to make some assumptions and get
some modeling done so that we can get to
conclusion I can't sit here today and
tell you which option I prefer because I
don't know if it's economic and whether
it's affordable for the public I also
don't know in the current economic
climate that it's the time for the
council to be not aligning with the
wastenet councils and the region so I
really feel
today I can't support any options
without some some detailed costings and
some assumptions being made
thank you councilor
councilor John gato
yeah I would agree with um Brett that we
do need to see the costs we've seen I've
seen a report in a Fair View on TV the
other night that a lot of councils are
recycling and then it ends up in
landfill and that's been happening all
around New Zealand because the
infrastructure is not there and we need
to look at an air region and wastenet is
probably needs to get up and running to
actually provide that infrastructure
because otherwise we haven't got any
costs
and our scale is so small it's not even
funny yeah and so basically we need to
look at
our green waste yes and a someone like
um
the line Works May provide that a
solution for that on a regional basis so
I think that's where it will lie it's
getting rid of that green waste into a
regional based facility
that is funded we'll have to fund to get
into that but I mean let the private
sector may actually do it for us
thank you councilor councilor Dixon and
then Council McKenzie oh thank you
worship I'd like to hear from Nikki
regarding John's point
about recycling just not going anywhere
and going into the landfill please
I just want to defend um recycling the
reason it ends up in landfill is because
there's not enough education and the
public will contaminate it and as soon
as you pick up a bin at the curbside
that has got a dead creature in it or a
dirty nappy or a coffee cup with half a
coffee in it you're an instantly
contaminating and that comes down to a
level of Education that has to be
part of any change you make if we can
educate the public about why recycling
is important the value of the materials
that they have in their hands and why
those materials need to be separated out
then you get good quality Recycling and
it goes to the right places and then yes
the business sector can make money out
of it but but not when we do a half cut
job and we end up with recycling that's
contaminated and Yen yeah it has to go
to land Focus no one can do anything
with it
thank you Nikki Council McKenzie
Nikki you've actually already answered
the question I was going to put was it's
more of a comment really
people can be naturally lazy
they will hide things in the other bin
just to make it go away there needs to
be some real incentive for them to
participate
and whatever we decide to do because
it's a natural thing
I'm going to say a naughty word people
can be bloody lazy
and you really have to find a way of
getting them to participate in whatever
we do it's just a comment I'd like to
put on there thank you
if their counselor councilor eight
thank you um just back to Nikki's
comment
um
about the education maybe our money is
better spent with the minimization
officer at the stage
with the education part of it
thank you councilor I would tend to
disagree I'd just like to remind
councilors of what Jason's point was
earlier that the bin lead time is is two
to three months
um these these options are it's likely
to be a three-bin system and we can
explore a full bin system so I I don't
see why we couldn't commit to
getting the the bins at least ordered
and on their way and then we have that
discussion about financials come and
you'll plan we simply can't sit around
and go we're not doing recycling
that's that's not fair on our rate paths
or our community
well there's what I'm what I'm
struggling with is we seem to be doing
this thing again of kicking the can down
the road and looking for for more
information to to make a decision we
kind of we need to give the the staff
some instruction about where we were
going with this
Council rate I think um given that we're
all very aware of the fact that we've
got rights to look at for the rest of
the year and where that's going to lead
us and I know that some councils not too
far from us actually are in the position
at the moment of
just status quo with their recycling
good bad or indifferent that's just a
fact so I think possibly we need to be
aware of where we spend our money and to
me Nikki's saying you can give them
another bin but if they contaminate it
it's still going to go to landfill so
until you actually start at the coal
face and educate people about what goes
in their bins what is the point
counselor Dixon I just would like to ask
are we going to have this forced upon us
anyway these options by the government
one of these options
I would say yes um I can't I can't say
when but I think it's coming these bins
are going to come you the recycling the
fact that you're you're one of two
districts in the country that aren't
recycling
um I think there's going to be
some hardlines that will come not in the
not too distant future regarding what
we're looking at with Recycling and
Organics
I think it's also outlined in the report
as well that with those levees That
central government is trying to push us
towards recycling because we're going to
be paying more and more to put things
over the top face I understand that yeah
Council red
um I've lost my train of thought now
um
I have to think about
councilor McDonald
just looking at the recommendations here
we're not actually going to make a
decision today at all because the we've
got to identify which of the five
options we think is referred and then
consult with the community the way I
read it so there's still going to be a
consultation so if we go with option
four today we're still going to have a
I don't know a six-week consultation
period then have to come back to the
next meeting and decide if that's the
option but it's very hard as Brett said
to decide anything without sort of some
sort of costings around things
that's my view councilman Farr
I thought I'd wait a week while you
worship before I didn't want to come
straight after you
um
I agree with the discussion so far but
if we actually look at it we can all say
what option we prefer but we have to
find out what the financial uh
recompense or the financial implications
uh with that and I think it's wrong to
indicate that we do Kick the Can down
the road and saying that we are prepared
to make a decision I'm happy to say what
option I look at here and prefer I just
want to know what's going to cost us it
can cost us some rate pays
um you know or air pocket the council
pocket in relation to some of the
comments regarding country waste uh yes
us people who live in the country we pay
for a green bin to be uplifted but we
have the option of removing the bottles
putting them in a box taking them to the
gore dump and putting them in the um the
bin that's there to have it recycled we
also bundle up our cardboard and we know
that if we bring our cardboard and our
paper in and give it to the parkiki
Lions it won't go into the dump it will
go and you know fund uh fund
um scholarships and various things
around town so I don't think we need to
lose sight of the fact that recycling
doesn't have it does happen it's just
I agree with the counselors saying we
just want some costings how much is this
if I say look option four looks great
you've got three bins there if I lived
in town and you're going to help me
create a worm farm I'd I'd go with it
but I just want to know what money it's
going to cost
so that's where I'd sort of stand on
that
Cuts over
the issue issues relating to costs I
hear and and I'm uncertain as to which
of the options after hearing that
discussion I would favor ahead of the
rest
um particularly what councilor Reed
indicated of having a waste minimization
person seems an easy step I'm wondering
if there's another easy step and that's
everyone has two bins in the urban area
sitting around their household at
present and I would think that the cost
of actually as a transition
of bringing in the tubing system in the
short term may be the way to go because
given the debate the more we discuss it
the longer a decision is going to take
to make and we need to get it right I
don't think that we should be jumping in
quickly and saying let's go with that
optional or another option even
providing for public consultation
this is one of the significant
environmental issues that the public the
young and and the people who have voted
for us to be around this table have
raised has been important to them so I I
just want to take a deep breath and and
say let's let's just not jump in Boots
and all and look at what can be done as
intermediate small steps
can I can I ask a question I don't know
who can answer this but if we were to go
down the road of selecting an option or
two what does it consultation actually
look like what do we what are we asking
the community
um say we're you know if we look at a
three bin option
um what kind of result are we looking
for here
three worship I think in terms of
consultation
I guess actually I'll go back a step the
way the the report particularly um
Nikki's report is
um drafted us to give all those five
options
um because
um clearly
there's certainly advantages and
disadvantages to all of those options uh
what we want to again the whole point of
going down the consultation road though
is to allow the community to provide you
with feedback about what they want and
how to how to go out there I understand
that there's some
um
a challenge in that because of a lack of
understanding of cost
um in terms of the the cost so just if I
can just provide some clarity on that
too what we're trying to indicate is
that through the existing recycling
budget that Council has in its
um
current annual plan and the costs we are
able to
um
understand at this point in time is that
we we believe that the existing budget
will meet those costs um I guess the
bigger concern though is the the waste
uh landfill costs and that's Indica you
know at this point that's indicated as
being somewhere around a 500 000
shortfall
um so that that's the immediate cost I
think that that faces Council the other
things uh the cost of the bins we can
reduce right down over a 10-year period
it's um you know sort of like a a couple
of dollars a year you know we we can at
per resident you know so we can reduce
those and lower the impact of those the
additional service
um is about eighty thousand dollars a
year to have because we've got an extra
day we still only need one truck to pick
it up so we've been able to assist and
and manage those
um the biggest concern though is that
waste to landfill cost that has been
progressing year upon year since 2019 at
250 000 a year plus on top of that the
increased waste Levy costs that's the um
the costs that we have to sort of face
and
um what we're trying to do I guess with
recycling is
hopefully offset that a little bit
um but it's it's a cost that faces their
community
thank you for that
um Jason hopefully that gives some
counselors some clarity around numbers I
just wanted to clarify that 500k
shortfall is that is it regardless of
whether we turn recycling back on or not
or is that option one versus all the
other options
if you I guess through your worship if
you leave under the status quo we're
utilizing the recycling budget to offset
that cost but it's not it's no longer
meeting it so the there is a a cost
discussion that we that we need to have
through the annual plan again because of
those increases in the waste Levy so we
haven't we haven't addressed those as a
council
thank you for that Jason
does it help give counselors concern
about numbers a bit more clarity or are
they still uneasy about numbers moving
forward okay
let's go
Council Hotel
I'm wondering is whether there is a path
of least resistant
and and this this talks about a
consultation process
and we need to be mindful of the amount
of things that we're Consulting on at
different times
um and and what I guess my question is
this do we need to go through a separate
consultation process or actually do
something as part of the annual plan
process
um I think when we see the costs and we
do need to see the costs of the options
when we do see those costs and take into
account other expenditure
um
uh issues that we've got before us that
um it's likely that something will fall
out quite logically so my question is I
guess for discussion is doesn't need to
be a separate consultation or let's deal
with it under the annual plan process
through your worship just an answer to
that question
um bear in mind the annual plan process
uh is not normally now one where you do
public engagement unless there is a
change of
mode of delivery of service
in this case we were proceeding with our
annual plan given that we're layout of
blocks to get the annual plan budgets
together on the basis that we wouldn't
be Consulting hence the recommendation
to do a separate engagement process to
get ahead of the annual plan if you like
given that council is a
uneasy with some of the the costings I
just I guess is there is there a
recommendation floating around what
costings we need so we can give
direction to the council so just to
clarify what uh Jason has said there
will be a 500K shortfall more or less
um as we use that recycling what has
been used to offset
um as it goes back into Recycling and
also if we would go is it options three
four and five would be an extra 80k for
this inclusive or service or does that
include option two as well
let's
just for option three four and five in
terms of the service for pickup because
it will be additional uh
yeah there's an additional four pickups
per four weeks so yeah
yeah so
the difference between option option
two sorry one and two and three four and
five is just 80k
um
plus that the 500k that we need to to
find the next shortfall
is there a recommendation rolling around
in terms of what what costings we still
need clarification on cancel the string
um so I'm not sure if there's a cost
thing or we can put it on the costings
but um if we could actually find out
what grants are available from the
government for this
like if we can get anything that reduces
it like it honestly we're at the bottom
of the pack we're only we're one of two
councils that aren't doing anything
um what's the chance next year they
decide to go right You've Got a Brand
recycling anyway
sorry just a point of order to councilor
Stringer we recycle cardboard we recycle
turn aluminum and glass we are in
Greenway so yeah we are recycling
I know but
so sorry counselor it's it's actually
stated in this report that we are one of
the two that is and that's what I was
clarifying with with Nikki
thank you we actually
um we do it differently because we've
got Packy Lions doing cardboard and 10
now and Cairns and then we've got the
green waste going to have fill with the
old old dump site so we're actually
disposing a lot of our Greenways and
doing recycling them but it's actually
not through the council's books and I
think that should be very much
encouraged
correct me if I'm wrong but this report
is discussing curbside only yeah which
poker headlines don't collect curbside
for houses uh Jason you had a further
comment
yeah I'm just wondering if I can
actually help uh facilitate the
discussion here I think
to give councilors a little bit more
Comfort I wonder if we
um
if staff bring back a report
to the next council meeting in April I
think one of the challenges has been
around the timing of this and our annual
plan process so I think
by the next council meeting we will have
a better understanding of the um the
budgets across the organization in terms
of the annual plan if we bring that back
within some more uh we're able to then
detail potentially the impact on on our
rate payers in terms of this the changes
to the service and
um and I don't think it holds us up
anyway I think we in terms of councilor
hovel's point about uh consultations we
do have a big issue out with our
community at the moment and then we'll
still run in the line of a timeline then
to go out towards the end of April
um
or early May for then
um to ask our community then about the
waste issue which we again know is a is
another one um and still potentially
bring something back to council ahead of
July 1st in terms of
um some comms around that so
how does that sound
thanks for that Jason councilor Dixon
I'll just have a comment
um I think parkiki lines to a great job
of collecting our paper and cardboard
but I still see there's 13 paper in our
in our waste so we need a lot of
Education around this and how we can
collect it and what we can do with it
[Music]
thank you for that counselor um
councilor Phillips
here you think you wish it then perhaps
then as part of that report
um that we have are constantly on then
on of a dedicated minimization officer
and her impact on air recycling whether
whether her cost aware of us in the long
term save us money as part of the of
part of that report
achievable Jason Alpha hemple here thank
you
we may be able to look at I guess the
impact of waste minimization offices in
other areas to understand that but it
will be difficult to put a number on
that I think um it will be in the
um the proof will be in the longer term
putting if we're able to reduce over
time the
the uh increase that we've seen over the
last four or five years um
then that will show and and we'll see
that Savings in terms of those waste
Levy costs as they are continuing to
ramp up so uh we can we can have a look
and see if we can provide some around
that but there's a that would certainly
be an outcome that we would be seeking
from anybody in that position as to as
to start to turn around that that
picture which is at the moment still
climbing in terms of our numbers uh at
tunstallen for
I think there's a recommendation
floating around there that we we have a
report to the next council with uh
costings I just want to make it very
clear to councils and more so the public
that if we are to not make a decision
here today we will miss that Target of
July 1 2023 which the the council had
indicated was going to be achievable
with that costings it'll also push us
out quite a bit past
if we're to go down the consultation
route of asking the community especially
if we stick to the three pin option
um so I would just like that to bear in
mind if someone has to bring a
recommendation that we
await further information
did someone want to put a recommendation
together
you wish that before you invite a
recommendation just if I could ask if
the proposed recommender uh perhaps
isolate whether they want costings on
options three four and five only or or
the whole kitten converter it would help
I think the staff to actually Focus the
Endeavors in a certain direction
Council Havel
we'll give it a go
um so my recommendation would be firstly
that the report being received secondly
that
the council staff prepare a further
report on the costings and
benefits
of
the five options identified and
also the benefit Costa costing the
benefits the options identified and the
employment of a dedicated waste
minimization officer
think of that could I just change that
slightly I believe we've actually put
the waste minimization officer before in
the annual plan to be regarded I feel
like we've done that at a previous
meeting I'm not sure whether we need to
do that again
it's in the recommendation but I'm
pretty sure we've done it a previous
meeting
yeah I don't think we need to do it
again I might head at home a bit yeah
I'm quite happy to run with it that's
cool uh do we have a debate on that one
Council Dixon I wasn't going to Second
it I was just going to say I I think
it's pointless doing option one and two
because that we're just going nowhere
with it and it's more cost and more time
and meet more resources for Council so
we should be doing three four and five
yeah I would tend to agree uh councilor
heister
I think you're right councilor Dixon but
also I don't think we I don't think if
any clearly understand what the current
cost is so unless we can say it's
currently costing you X to do nothing
um it won't
it won't balance the the new costs of
the other options so I think it is
useful to to table
um what the status code costing is
Jason
uh just to maybe help clarify that I
don't think that the pulling together
the previous two options probably isn't
too difficult we've got we can go back
and look at 2020 figures and just apply
um the the increases
um in terms of the overall tonnage in
costs so we can we can yeah there's not
as as difficult the the hardest part
again about this is trying to predict
the amount of tons of recycling that's
going to be processed to understand
those costs but will um we'll make some
assumptions and provide a a best
estimate to councilors to inform that
decision
thank you for that clarification uh
Jason and also councilor heisted for
that I I still am uncomfortable pursuing
options one and two because if we we get
those costings and we say hey it's going
to be quite expensive for recycling
we're really going to turn around to our
community and go and we can't do it
we're not going to recycle we're going
to stay in that bottom two of New
Zealand who aren't recycling
[Music]
seconded by councilor heisted do we have
any further discussion on the matter
councilor Stringer just to confirm it's
for all five options where okay
thank you for any further discussion so
it's costings on all five options to be
presented at the next meeting in
benefits and benefits yeah
yeah
and minimization officer we're going to
keep that in there even though it's
costing costings yeah yeah yeah no no
good suggestion
any further discussion
oh Council Road
apart from what we're talking about at
the table but the recycling just the
fact that some people may be watching
um some of the chain stores the major
stores around the area are actually
providing at a very low level but miter
10 takes Back Garden pots and things
that your pants you buy your plants and
there's a big bin there to put them in
um you only have yourself to wash them
out when you take them in they're also
recycling old uh light bulbs as well
so it's always positive to see some of
these bigger places leading the way
thank you Council yes there are some
businesses who are Miles ahead of us in
the recycling space
any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
aye please be recorded as against the
motion has carried
foreign
River Point number seven the matoda
River Crossing community engagement
update uh do we have any further comment
from the report writer
thank you worship
um yes this is obviously just a report
is just a bit of an update on how things
have been progressing with the community
engagement
um following the discussion at the
February council meeting
um obviously been trying to push forward
with this as quickly as possible in the
community engagement process was
officially launched on Sunday at the
councils on the Fly
event
um I might just pass to the GM of
communications and
customer support to provide a bit of
comment around how the community
engagement's gone so far
well thank you and through the chair
um we're only two days in and I have to
say um I think it's been very successful
on our initial pop-up session on the Fly
we had really good feedback and good
engagement from people I also like to
say a big thank you to the councilors
who turned up to support us too that was
great to see so in terms of um the
feedback we've received to date
um and the last we've only been open for
two days that we've already received
over a hundred feedback forms online
we've had 216 people visit our page and
had 59 documents downloaded so I think
it would be fair to say that there is a
high degree of public interest in this
and public engagement
um we've still got you know three and a
half weeks to go three more pop-up
sessions as a double page ad in
tomorrow's in sign with the feedback
form for those people who don't want to
engage online
so um yeah it's going to be um I think
it's I'm going to be very successful
outcome all around
thank you there Sonia and thank you for
that Matt just just before I open up to
to questions for the report writer I
just I just want to touch on a few
points
um firstly a big thank you to both Sonia
Matt and Jason for the the and anyone
else
um who's put in some massive effort to
get this um over the line
um it really shows that when we can
provide good governance towards our
staff they can produce some fantastic
outcomes so that is really really great
um I just wanted to touch on a few
points
um a bit of I guess explanation around
some of the criticism so yes in the
meeting it was asked for for a public
meeting that was discussed with staff
and in this report it indicates that
it's um rather than having one public
meeting that can go can go Wayward it
was much better to have full public
engagements one of those being on the
Fly and it went very very successfully
we got a lot of Engagement so it was
fantastic to see people on about sharing
their points
uh they're they have been comments out
in the public that there is a bias
towards the bridge
um though that even that feedback has
been heard um so we are getting some
imagery added to the website so that
there's pictures of the drilling to to
even that up a bit to prove that we
really are trying for it for a fair
um assessment here and doing our bestest
on that
um that just comes with the pace
um we can't really do a whole lot of
consultation on the consultation
document beforehand
um but like I say the the pace has been
fantastic so thank you to the staff on
that one do we have any questions for
either Matt or uh Sonia on this report
cancel addiction
thank you well should I just have a
comment um about the drop-in sessions I
know that the uh during the day and I
wonder if we need one
um at five o'clock or times that people
who are working or work out of town can
actually
come into a drop-in session or do you
think they're covered enough with the
Facebook and the inside
yeah
uh through the chair
um a lot to be fair ideally yeah maybe
one in the evening but it was just to
fit it in with that time frame I suppose
um and to go to those communities of
Interest we're looking at the Oak Street
one is the lunch time so hopefully
there'll be when people you know are
taking a break from if they're working
in town and things like that there are
other multiple channels and as I say the
all the feedback we've received to date
as as online and I think that's what
most of it will come from to be for you
okay
I think if that cancel any further
questions
ah Council Mackenzie
as most of you guys are probably aware I
was at on the fly on Sunday I was not
there as a counselor I was there as the
EMC and I did have quite a few people
save me
um
that the
information leaflet was biased this this
is their opinion not mine I did have
people come up to me and say it's biased
in favor of the bridge option but like
you're saying Ben they are engaging
though
these folks were engaging but their
thoughts were when you look at the back
of it
um you had the four options there and
they say well where's the under the
river one it was up a little bit higher
and smaller print but that's just
comments that came to me Sonia it's
nothing
aimed with anybody or anything like that
because I was here as the EMC for the
day but they do they're aware of what I
do and they did come and make that
comment to me that's all
if I can perhaps help
um just yeah through the chair um look
that was a valid comment too and you
know people raised that with us and so
we have revised it and we've included
imagery of where the um trenching will
go or the drilling will go
um there's yeah it was an oversight but
we have updated it so all our imagery
online now and what we'll be taking out
to the public will include that
thank you for that and just for anyone
listening and or in the room if you are
to fill out the form if you are in favor
of the drilling option just tick that
you're in favor of the dribbling option
you don't have to go through and pick
options uh I through D um it is just
just take it and a new form
any further discussion on
this item
no okay the recommendation is that the
report be received and that the accounts
will know the proposed changes the
community engagement process for the
matoto rubber Crossing project as
outlined in the above report do I have a
mover councilor Guardian seconded by
councilor Max and now uh I will put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
financial report to 31 December 2022
did Lorne I want to speak to this report
at all
no um through your worship
um yes
to be honest this result is not
unexpected
um staff have been signaling issues and
pressures around inflation around wage
costs for many many months right back to
last year's annual plan and last year's
annual plan we identified a few areas
that where there's inflationary
pressures
Council adopted an annual plan that had
a rates increase less than inflation so
we were always going to have a cost
there that we could not control we've
got some classic examples this year
we've got tagging and testing which is a
health and safety compliance issue we
need to make sure all the electrical
equipment is up to standard and those
increases that could come coming between
500 and a thousand percent increase this
is the kind of thing that we cannot
control we have to do another one is New
Zealand post and they're looking at a 20
to 30 increase in their costs this year
ramping up to between 100 and to 120
over the next three years again we're
factoring this in we know it's there and
it's beyond our sphere of control
but to touch on the highlights or the
low lights of of the financial report
however you might want to look at it
um you know there's
we're tracking we're tracking with our
rates we're tracking with our subsidies
and grants you know we've had transition
funding that is helping um backfill or
get contractors in to help with their
three Waters transition work
um we have you know we are on the
downside of employee costs but again
it's a tight Market unemployment is at
low levels it's difficult to attract
skilled labor and we are having we're
singing inflationary increases of 30 and
some very highly skilled areas and even
some non-skilled areas you know it's
really important to attract and retain
the staff that we have we've got a
really good culture in the organization
and unfortunately it comes at a cost you
know we've we've been pushing staff for
a long long time and you know we we
can't push them too much more before
they break
um in relation to you know we have had
an article of unexpected items that
we've found as we've undertaken work one
of the items we've found when we're
doing the authority upgrade is that
there were a number of servers that
Hendon have the appropriate licenses
again we have to have those licenses so
we don't face fines so we are
appropriately covered and have that
Assurance there is a an issue dating
back many many years
um back to 2013 I believe
um and then again the patches that we're
required to bring the bring software up
to date so that we could upgrade
but one of the biggest things that set
us as far as expenditure goes is
depreciation and that accounts for
almost
um just just under half of what the
unfavorable variance and expenditure is
and this is a result of the revaluations
that occurred at the end of last year
Council head budgeted for an increase in
evaluation of our assets we had budgeted
close to 23 million increase what came
through was a 66 million dollar increase
so we're down two-thirds on the increase
in depreciation on what we had
anticipated so for the six months to
December that's six hundred thousand
dollars in for year in that'll be 1.2
million now there is a paper going I'm
going to present a paper to the next
council meeting around options around
depreciation there is an option not to
fully fund the depreciation for the
increase in revaluation of assets and
this is a tactic that has been employed
by a number of councils around the
country of those surveyed recently 72
percent were going to be undertaking
that that option so I'll prepare per
paper to bring back to council for the
for the next for the April council
meeting
um but I'm happy to probably talked
enough I'm happy to take some more
questions
thank you for that lornae
um I guess the only question from me is
and this probably is a stupid question
but um how are we tracking compared to
other councils I'm assuming we're not
alone in in this this deficit
um so you worship without having done
the research I've been focusing on us
rather than what everyone else is doing
as far as their year-to-date and
performance goes I would expect their
experiences some of the same same
pressures and we are seeing that with
some of the indications and rates and
creases that are coming out from
neighboring councils you know they're
sitting in between that 10 and 18 from
some of the ones I've seen so far so the
pressure serving felt throughout the
sector
any questions for lornay on this report
counselor gara
I presume it's a typing area and
expenditure with 44 599
000. yes yep thank you it's um if you
look on the second page over it's got
the correct figure on there just pure
typo
there's a concern to see um deficits and
that's probably why the council's pretty
cautious of making decisions at the
moment do we see an annual plan
councilor Dixon and then Council heisted
um I was just running some confirmation
I'm I'm a little bit concerned about the
planning consultants for the RMA is 230k
up compared to the budget and I know
we're ahead of time what but it also
um
the consent being issued
the fees are costing more and I have
heard people saying too that their fees
for consents are a lot higher than they
anticipated I'm just I know that you
can't answer that lornay and I
appreciate that but
um yes it's just quite concerning that
we're seeing both those figures well up
really and and the fees for consents up
as well so I was could you
preps verify that
through you you worship yes but the
planning function is delivered
predominantly via a contract for the
property group they provide a very high
level of Professional Service but you do
pay for it
the first six months is notable for the
fact that we didn't have any in-house
planning function we have now employed a
young graduate and Bridget who's doing a
really great job and it means that some
of the more basic functions that the
property group were doing in the first
six months of this year could be a no
planning function and now being absorbed
by Bridget so that's one of the things
we can do to sort of stop the adverse
result in terms of the fees of planning
applicants are charged look that's the
reality of the cost of a service and
planning is a user pays function
predominantly so if you apply for
resource consent and we have
professional staff
critiquing that consent it's not
reasonable for the ratepayer to pay for
the cost therefore the user pays and
those fees have been high but I've I've
seen the schedule and I don't think
myself there they're outrageous have
been probably I know Ephesian charges
we're talking about increasing the
deposit because the deposit which thinks
about 750 it's just not enough to cover
most of the fees seem to be in the area
of one to two thousand from like off the
top of my head
um and if you get a decent deposit then
the final bill paid by the applicant
hopefully is not too much if it's too
low they get a bill at the end of it and
they get a shock
uh councilor mcdonell
uh Lorna or just through through the
this worship uh the year end we'll be
looking at it because you look at these
costs here employee costs and other
costs they're just going to continue for
the year there's no
imbalance first six months second six
months so we're going to be looking at
about a two and a half million dollar
deficited year end less if we but if we
go to just go back and reverse that
depreciation we're back back to about
1.3 1.4 is that fear comment
uh yet through your worship yesterday
there's a fair comment
um the depreciation is a paper exercise
but it's normally good practice to try
and fund the replacement of your assets
um but in times like this you can
actually have a graduated scale and over
a number of years move towards coming
back to 100 fully funded depreciation
and I think given the shock that we have
had with this that there would be a
prudent a prudent approach but again we
would want to bring a paper back to
council to get Council to approve that
that particular position
you know there is an opportunity to talk
to managers but we have to talk to each
budget manage to see if there's places
that they can save but with three months
left of the Year realistically that's
chances that are pretty slim
any further questions
I think I just hit one here open to
staff it says there's a number of
differing numbers but the the question's
still the same around parks and reserves
being over by 53k or by 160k
um is there a plan to get that back on
track with with the you know limited
time lift and and if so kind of what
that might look like yep it's really
worship
um parks and reserves get quite often
seasonal so whilst the budget is divided
by 12 to make it simple um in this in
the current format we use there is a
chance that there are spending for the
final quarter of the year will come back
again a discussion will need to be had
with the with the manager
um what we have found though there's
been a couple of extra projects put on
like the library project like the like
met High Ridge there's also been some
maintenance that has been required due
to trees that have been found to be
rotten and found to be a risk so there's
some reactive that has to happen in
these instances but it is a discussion
that we will have with with managers
going forward
if that any further discussion councilor
Phillips
I think you worship uh can you just um
give me the answer to why the project
art there was a variance of 60k what was
that for
eign
funded so whilst we say it sits there as
index as an expenditure variant
um it's not completely so with with
project act they took on additional
staff for the specific project they're
doing at the moment
um that we did not have that information
at the time of annual plan there's also
a departure of a long-term staff member
who had a significant amount of annual
leave which again adds to as to the um
the cost on departure so that's why we
encourage our staff to take their leave
any further discussion
uh Council Stringer
uh through his worship
um are there any potential areas where
you see we could save money or cut down
this deficit
um with the year remaining um I would
like I said I'd need to sit down with
budget managers for them to get an
understanding they're the ones that know
the area as well and know what how
they're tracking so it would be time
spent for my management accountant and I
to get around to the 15 budget holders
it seems like we've we've asked all the
questions happy
so the recommendation is that the
financial report of the 31 December 2022
be received could I get a move for that
please councilor McDonald and a seconder
uh councilor hotel I will put the motion
if there's no further discussion all
those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
next we have the local government
statement
did we have any further comment from the
trivia on this one
not just a couple of couple of minor
amendments you were that have just
Arisen to decision did you have didn't
ordered
there were some
okay there's just some minor tweaks in
the document uh that don't alter the the
substance but there are some but just in
terms of
um
the reference to for example
the representation review and the way in
which
representation by Maori is handled he's
been a legislative change so there's
been some tweaking words in that regard
so if your motion can allow for some
minor technical amendments that make
this statement correct that would be
good
a counselor got on and then Council the
Stringer does we do we have to delete
three Waters in This Global government
statement for this government coming
it's in there for the coming year but
it's got in that election year it's
going to roll out
uh what page you on
[Applause]
page 27
45.
yeah that's a statement that's correct
as at this point in time we have Asset
Management plans for water
um and until such time as the uh legal
transfer is affected uh that's that's
correct at this time it could well be
that we will lead to amend our
government statement in the aftermath of
the three Waters reforms but it's still
a reasonable bit that even if the reform
process still continues in its current
form there may well still be a delay in
the implementation date
com
uh yeah since we're making amendments
can we please look at page 14 page 15
where we have added the new councils in
I noticed that uh home addresses will be
published and
as opposed to the previous councilors
that are still in there at their email
addresses included don't want an email
address but um is there a reason we'll
be publishing home addresses
uh through you your worship that's one
of the things we noted as an
inconsistency so we can remove the
postal addresses and leave it as per
previously so just email addresses only
uh given that there was a point that I
raised that had written down as well
could we also have um when this when
it's done this agenda item removed and
then republished um just so that it
doesn't because I thought it's publicly
accessible at the moment so
um I don't want to put those new
councils Under uh Council over
well and just just quickly through some
other things I noticed a number of the
telephone numbers were also Incorrect
and some details are missing so I think
each councilor needs to have a look at
that if it's not on your list page five
reference to the fire prevention by law
is incorrect it says 2008 and it was um
effective from 2005
um page 27 reference to the asset
management plans the ultimate line has
got a number of details dates missing
um page 28 section 15.1 refers to
contact details with Council and tenno
should be added to that page 30 request
for official information just here's the
post office box details of council
should also refer to email I guess they
come in the net form
thank you councilor very particular as
always you love it
um any other comments
all happy oh sorry there was one other
one that I noticed that all the general
managers have referred to except in the
document except for the general manager
of people and culture and I'm just
wondering if there was a reason for that
I can assure you in the presence of the
general manager people and culture there
is no reason for that it's just a slight
oversight and will be incorporated
very important position in person
thank you vet councilor councilor Dixon
my phone number is incorrect so will I
just send an email to Susan correcting
that okay thank you
any further of it edits
uh the recommendation is that the
updated local government statement be
adopted and made available to the public
following those amendments do I have a
mover councilor Hotel secondary
councilor mcdonell uh I will put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
proposed fees and charges for the higher
of the community rooms at James [__]
Community Center 2023 2020 oh sorry 2022
uh did the management accountant or the
gym of course would support how many for
the comment
uh through your worship I'm quite happy
to take the reporters read we will be
revising these as we get to see how
we'll probably be 18 months off before
we get to see how well the facility is
used and whether um whether it's
covering its costs and as part of the
revenue and financing policy review that
we performed in the long-term planning
process
um the funding of this will be looked at
anyway so and the instruments to get it
up and running into to set some
expectations without
um taking business away from our fellow
fellow ratepayers and businesses
thank you for that Lorne do we have any
questions full on a on this report
our Council hosted
thank you just through you Mr Mayor
during the design phase I may be able to
date there were some other rooms
throughout the library that that were
going to be available
for public use
do they still remainder and are they
covered by this or was that a separate
um
they still remain there's a couple of
community rooms off top of my head in
the library itself
but this report confines itself to the
community rooms which people would
normally associate with the the JC Wing
I'm not sure what the library's manager
has intended in regard to whether there
is a charging regime that will operate
in those rooms
do you know Rick's might be able to help
me but this this can find itself to the
the community rooms yeah the intent is
for the library rooms to be used for
Library activities and programs not to
necessarily be rented out for public use
as such so they've been separated out
from the community center charges
sorry is that likely to affect our
business on the the community rooms will
people not just want to use the the free
ones they will be referred to the
community center rooms the the rooms
that will be in the library are used for
Library activities and research and
genealogy
um and that's one of the rooms
um and the other is for Library related
activities but at this stage uh in
conversation with the library manager
there was no intention for
charging for those rooms for those
Library related activities
if the intent is for Council to offer
those for non-library related activities
that's another conversation we would
have to have
because it's right in the middle of a
library space
could I and this might be a long shot
but could I ask what a library related
activity is considering there's a
there's a kitchenette in that room well
primarily to do with research genealogy
um we're using the resources in the
library
that would they would have access
because they're in the middle of a
library space
oh cancel Houston
sorry during during the design phase
there was a an Express I mean there
wasn't a concern expressed by the
councils at that time that with the
reduced number of rooms available in the
in the new um
Community facility that there would be
availability of of rooms in the library
for use so it's
from where I said it wasn't it's not a
new item it was actually something that
was
was socialized and probably intended but
um yeah maybe it's just me three year
you worship it's news to me
um and I'll follow it up and come back
to you
um because from a logistical
operational perspective
offering community space which is not
Library related in a library we'll have
some logistical issues that obviously
weren't discussed as part of the
previous council's conversations but
we'll we'll we'll follow that through
and come back to you isn't it no problem
and to worship my understanding is
somewhere between Council high stensons
and Rex cables and that I thought the
community rooms were going to be an
overflow point if the if the community
center proper would need to be fully
booked before someone could look into
the Library community rooms and say can
we jump in there and and it could well
be for a fee because it's a similar use
to what the community center route
should be
that's that's how I answered it to be
I just like to say that my understanding
was too that those rooms were going to
be open to the public for public hire
when we discussed the library
um yes the whole infrastructure of it
so as I say I'll I'll bring I'll put
some thought into this uh and bring back
some logistical and operational
challenges to ask you to solve uh if
we're to as an example if we were to
hire out a room in the middle of a
library at night when the library is not
it doesn't have personally I'll
associate with it it creates a whole
host of security related issues that I
can bring back to the table and we can
we can come up with some sort of Sheed
solution if that's the path but further
to Mr parry's comment I would like to
think that it will be on the basis of a
overflow requirement rather than uh
um you know an initial choice but we
need to resolve that because there are
some significant security and logistical
operational
issues that you know can't just be
solved here on the on the hoof at the
moment
I just wanted to do we need to sit then
fees for that room if there happens to
be overflow I recognize that the room
the community rooms open on Friday there
could be a whole lot of interest in
people wanting to book it out do we need
to set a fee for what that may look like
if if they need to use the Overflow room
well I understand if it's on you'll
correctly is it's it's currently one
it's not available for public booking
through the booking system but Sonya
oh yeah through you the worship
um when we were looking at
um the community rooms it won't be
available for public use until after
Easter people will be able to make
bookings but it's not going to be open
for public use so I've been told until
after Easter
um we're not sure about the library at
this stage
I'm sorry and I
back when this was being discussed I
clearly remember the genealogy Society
being one of the main uses upstairs in
the library and biggest belief that
anybody would want to um actually hire
it at night time and so I think that
sort of precludes anything
it would be daytime higher maybe some of
the smaller
smaller groups that may want to have a
quick meeting something like that that
would be that was my understanding at
the time
but I'm happy to be led by what you find
Council Phillips
thank you worship uh just a question on
on the cost per day running in around
about 520 if you want to hire out
uh the maximum amount with 272 million
people is that on par with the other
rooms and spaces available within the
district
my management accountant at the time had
done a ring around and found what the
costs were around other places and it
was in line with with them as far as I
was aware
indicated
is it higher or lower
because if we want the to use these
rooms we need to be just on par I think
without having that information in front
of me it's it's for what I understand
it's very very similar but I don't have
that exact information to hand
I also think through your worship you
need to reflect the fact that it's a
brand spanking new facility and so if
there is a little bit of a premium it
will probably reflect the condition that
or that the quality of the venue that
you'll hire
you can understand a question of Sonia
around the an availability tool Easter
what's the reasoning behind that
decision you may have to direct that
else we're sorry that was just the
information I was provided
oh yeah through your worship um it was
an operational decision to make
um
we had indications that the community
center wouldn't be completely finished
and we didn't want to rush into opening
something that wasn't ready to be opened
so we made the decision early on to
leave it till after Easter to allow all
the pieces to be brought in place to
allow Furniture to arrive and for it to
be set up properly and to get the fee
structure through
uh just recognizing that we're opening
the facility on Friday has it been
clearly communicated that people won't
be able to use the community rooms until
after Easter
through the chair that will be the case
yes
Council Dixon
just wondering if we need to um if
there's any thought about bonding people
because if there's any damage
to any of the rooms that
um that would be covered by a bond yep
through your worship that's part of the
terms and conditions of of hiring the
place there is a there is a deposit
required for before booking it again
those were some of the operational stuff
we wanted to make sure we had in place
before opening and not making sure it
was open to you know too soon so this
all takes time it all takes um manpower
to put in place and so that's why that's
why the part of the decision was made
Council mcphire
it's just true you worship um
I think councilor Dixon might have
covered what I said I was going to ask
around vetting obviously online
availability and people that will be
renting a council premises I take it to
be some sort of vetting process or
depending on who's going to hire it I
would take that as a given
criteria around the case and reportable
criteria around discount and waiver I
believe I would support the fact that
the staff previously had
had the ability to be able to cater with
that quite nicely but I believe we
should get a review on who's actually
been using them within six months who's
used the building and which groups
and the second third matter is in
regards to the users of the old James
[__] Wing there's a community room
and I know we've all probably been into
various groups here over the years have
we have related liaise with them around
the use of the new building the ones
that were moved
moved to other places or used other
facilities Garden
Club I believe and the embroiderers and
the various small user groups
in bowling
and where they fit in a waiver scheme
probably would be the important thing
that's all
right
through your Worship in regards to the
bowling Club in the end they've
Amalgamated with one of the other
bowling teams which is about the time
that we notified them that it was
unfeasible to have the wooden floor
because of the cost of leveling the
wooden floor Etc
so in the long run they
have Amalgamated with another another
club anyway
and I do believe there's a couple of
groups that have still been
being supported in the meantime
yes three worship there's a number a
couple of organizations that have had a
subsidy in place for having to use other
other rooms and the difference between
the cost previously and the cost that
they're currently incurring
communication at my business my
knowledge has not gone out at this stage
around that and again it's part of our
part of our closing the loop before we
open
before we make them available
thank you for I think that's a good
suggestion counselor around a six-month
review I think also if we're to move the
recommendation uh that we authorized
staff to assess that that might come
into that report as well if there are
any decisions that staff have made just
so we have an understanding of kind of
what's being waived and what's not
um
do we have any further discussion
can we get into the recommendations
get into the recommendations so first
off that the report is received that the
council adopt the fees and charges of
the community rooms for inclusion on
their schedule of fees and charges for
the year commencing one July 2022 and
the council authorizes access to
discounts or and or way fees on a
case-by-case basis and that there will
be a six-month review that will come to
Council of who has been using the
community space and who has been given a
discount or waived fees could I get a
mover for that motion please councilor
Richard mcphail and a seconder councilor
Dixon
um
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
James coming community center and
library development project update would
you like to speak to this one at all
Steve
you think she worship we're now in the
home straight with an opening on Friday
um
the library has been a hive of activity
for the past well obviously for
construction but trying to just get all
the finishing touches
completed
um I've got to say that all involved
we've done a sterling job you would have
seen our own staff just transform the
grounds in the recent couple of weeks
going from a Barren landscape where I
personally wondered whether we're living
I run a little bit a bit late to
suddenly warmth far here it is
a couple of minor little issues still to
work through the next 24 hours but we'll
be ready for the minister and other
celebrities and think of trees when it's
opened on the 24th of March
and pleasing to report that uh you know
this is a big project
undertaken
at a time where there was a lot of cost
and inflation uncertainty and the fact
that we've been now deliver it and what
is also a remodeling or renovation
project which has with a inherent cost
risk that we've been able to deliver it
within budget timing wise we're probably
a couple of months out but that's not
too bad in my humble view given the
procurement issues with covert related
and delays that we've experienced along
the way so looking forward to Friday
thank you for that Steve
um yeah so am I Friday's going to be a
good day I encourage anyone sitting here
and and listening at home to come along
and see that opening um hear from myself
and the minister and a number of other
key speakers and I hope to see councils
there as well if they can make it
do we have any questions for the
particular uh councilor read not for the
chief executive um two comments in a
question for a Communications officer
two comments they were lined up quite
deep on Sunday just
looking in at the building and all the
comments were very positive and it was
also really good to see the curb and
channeling on the other side of the road
that'll make a big difference to the
traffic worries for a lot of people
um and the question I would ask Sonja is
um
because the opening is Friday is there
any way we could well I'm making an
assumption I'll assume that you've
already
it's like come out on antenna that
members of the public I've had two phone
calls in the last 24 hours we hear it's
opening how do we know what time it is
through the chair
um there was a um a notice in
um
thank you for that Sonia so just for
anyone that didn't hear the Articles
will be going out and the enzyme this
week to make sure that people are aware
Council stranger
uh through his worship
wounded Road cones around the place be
removed by Friday so we opened up those
extra parking slots and get rid of that
bright orange
I'm sure they will be but I don't want
to preempt Murray's Council I probably
have but
the street worship uh yeah that's
definitely Our intention unless there's
something that's particularly unsafe uh
still at that stage but um I I don't
foresee that being the case
um that there's a possibility that some
of the ash building that was meant to be
done mid this week may be delayed but
it'll still be in a safe condition
um so we'll we'll make sure there's no
Road guns around
um for Friday
just the clarification Council you're
not joining mere Wayne Brown in his war
against rogones
fantastic do we have any further comment
uh Council McKenzie
uh just a quick comment there being I
can help spread the word if Council
would like me to do so
I think Sonya would appreciate that yeah
it'd be great uh Katie's just suggested
that he will spread the word on his
radio station uh yes so we'll be putting
out a media advisory as soon as we get
all the details lined up that'll go to
all the local channels including
yourself thank you
the only one you mean
thank you
could I please have a move that this
report is received councilor Reed and
seconded by councilor John Guardian all
those in favor please say aye and
against the motion is carried now we've
been here for two hours and our standing
orders permit um it's time to take five
minute break um so we'll reconvene in
five minutes at 6 16. thank you
councilors
thank you
just slowly pull it back in towards and
we'll just wait on Steve just run away
all right so let's get back into it uh
left on a bit of a cliffhanger there so
next up is number 12 proposed demolition
of the matoda pool building would Neil
like to speak to this report
thank you
in regards to this report it follows on
from a recommendations at the recent
Matera community board and I need to
stress that I've there's no disrespect
intended for the material community
board they're doing a great job
in regards to this building
my concerns were the saving of certain
portions of the building and I have put
details into this report as to
Hawaii
certain savings may end up being a
greater cost
so hopefully just to clarify aspects of
the whole dim possible demolition of
that area and for a future
Park especially a water park type aspect
um
just hope that that report answers most
of the questions might come to hand
and they'll be pleased to take any
questions
thank you for Daniel I'll Now open up to
questions to Neil um we also have the
chair of the community board in
attendance so um she's comfortable um
she may be able to provide some context
of where the community board was coming
from if there are any questions for her
too
no questions
puts straightforward
uh councilor Stringer
through his worship
um
to the community board here's the
community board considered selling the
building standing
like Council retains land but the
building sold as a going concern to
someone to relocate elsewhere that maybe
more maybe more of a question for for
Neil um than Nicki but feel free to come
up mick as well
um so it was around the sale where they
you could I'm guessing take off the
building and sell it for parts
through your worship the
costing that we've done is basically on
demolition
and they would
try to recycle as much as possible from
that process there is not a lot of
material there that would be able to be
sold sold off in a reusable condition
if that is there any other questions
I'm just wondering whether there's any
aspect that's in the report that the
chair of the community board wants to
comment on
um
through your worship I think the
report's very well written and we will
we're happy to just back the Council on
their decision
I don't I don't think it's addressed in
this report I mean I I know the figure
but um just for clarification for
councils what would the proposed
demolition be like unless I've missed it
in the report
after you worship this was
probably 12 months
possibly ago and we had two uh quotes
from demolition companies and one was
158 000 the other was 165.
and if we do proceed I would be
re-asking those particular companies and
a material company that has done
demolition as well
uh sorry this question before we go to
council heisted would it be safe to
assume that's probably going to be more
in the ballpark of 200k now with
inflation and hard to say
if 200 was put aside that would also
cover some of the
um
clearing any residue because there that
did not include the demolition of the
Furnace
but
councilor Phillips may know anything
about the furnace but I don't believe
there would any be any resale value
because there's cold call forward
can I just ask the staff a question then
um
if we were to pull down the front
section of the building and the rest of
the building would that site become a
hail site
because that that creates real problems
for us in the future if
um you wanted to build something on it
and I and we know we know from past
experience what hail sites are like
um yeah and I don't think they've done
our homework so much in that aspect if
we do demolish it
completely what would happen
and the other question that I have is
part of the recommendation of counselors
around the table do decide to demolish
it that I'd like
the first
part of the
um
sentence to say at the cost of council
and therefore the council is responsible
and not the battery board
he thinks three to to Neil Neil there's
a you know there's a stage two
um proposed and I just wonder is there
any efficiency in terms of
pre-demolishing the building to enable
what that project may be or approaching
it as a whole whole project and once the
Project's understood
um you know tendering the demolition as
well as the construction right is it is
it to the advantage of the council to
piecemeal
demolish first and then build later just
seems to me a bit fragmented but
interested in your view you may may or
may want to
through your worship the one situation
would be it could be two different
companies that would be specialized
involved
in regards to the poll as to how much
infrastructure would need to be dug out
and there is a specific requirement to
fill the pool in a specific way that it
does not
from either the water table or
dripping down later on
so it could we're really dealing with
two different aspects of it but in the
big picture when you meet just H2 I'm
not privy to what a lot of that was but
as far as the water park zero depth
quarter pack idea it was going to have
to be squeezed in between the pump track
and in the existing building
so once the building is down you've
actually then got the capacity to
um
look at a water pitcher of what the
designated playground area would be
I guess I'm asking it around probably
that civil's component in terms of what
what goes on top dictates what what
level of remediation or or you need to
do on the on the reclaim of it pool area
for example
um you know just yeah take your point
but I guess I looked and it'll come into
the when we debate I looked at it as a
stage two required some addressing of
the building as well as
you know building the new water park or
whatever that stage the community board
decide and um you know a group of
funders council better off funding being
part of
sure
sure you worship to the counselor's
comments
up to Neil the Paul has always been
there
and I think that
um
affected the way people looked at Waters
the stage two what's the next stage so
if the decision is made to demolish
your comments are quite right that it we
could look at the
you know holding off the Demolition and
seeing what construction companies are
able to do because
yeah
because even right at this point in time
now that decision has not been to
demolish the building
thank you for that now I I'd like to
yeah support that idea by councilor
heisted I think into Neville's points as
well this needs to be a one-long project
so the demolition it stays a
construction site so the Demolition and
the new project all come to Fortune all
on one one big swoop we do have
vandalism on that site at you know
Atomic Park already adding a demolished
building it will only add to that so
there's a there's also the thing as well
we we're going to have to find a sum of
around 200k in the budget too
um so whether that's an annual plan
um discussion or it needs to be an ltp
discussion um it's also an issue we
won't be able to just
um pull that money out of thin air
I wonder if there is a recommendation
that we will endorse the demolish of the
building but leave it to the community
board to develop a full project so
demolish right through to however that
that better off funding is going to be
spent on the on topic 2 so italic stage
type 2 is sorry
Turlock Park stage two has included
including the demolition um but we we
agree to set some money aside and then
they plan or furthermore ltp process
sound like a Way Forward
Council room
um just like to ask Nikki what she
thinks of that as a suggestion
I in an Ideal World the council would
have pulled down the building when it
shut the doors and the community board
wouldn't even have to be having this
discussion it's
painful enough that we had to put that
recommendation
through for the pool to be demolished
because a lot of well the other members
of the board
thought that when they were campaigning
that they would be able to get the pool
reopened
um
which after getting all the information
we now know isn't viable it's so
yeah it's a hard one we we want stage
two to be convinced stage two can't be
convinced while there's a derelict
building looking pretty rugged in our
community
um
yeah
it's
it's not ideal
is there any any further comment
um
I I think there's I think there's a kind
of agreement around the table that the
council is happy to take the onus of the
of the demolition so that's that's not
put on the community board and the
communities I Community Awards ideas for
telek Park will ultimately be the the
Revival of that that site so I think
that can that determination can be made
but I think in terms of the project I
guess the council takes care of the
Demolition and then it rolls into
the the new development as the community
board recommends
uh Council McKenzie
uh just a quick comment from yours truly
Neville or Nikki you can probably answer
this one does the old dive pull
underneath it have to be removed
it doesn't
because it goes down some way doesn't it
oh well the question the question is is
the is the pool actually floats during
the
um
period where there's no retention in the
water to keep the what keep the axle
pole down so when the pool was empty it
was floating
with with the high top the high tide
total and that's only because of the way
it was constructed and the other one was
pulled down was there not a a deep
diving pool uh it was indeed it wasn't
deep wasn't it so it wasn't deep deep no
no thank you for that
I might put a recommendation out there
uh that the the council endorses the
demolition of the matoda pool
um
with taking consideration to finding
that putting aside the money in the the
annual plan
um while
the Matata community board comes up with
a plan for telek stage two Atomic Park
stage two
um the council agrees to do a some sort
of pamphlet drop to Matata residents
outlining why the pool is closing and
hold a drop in session for atollic Park
I guess just a note on that
recommendation
um that we do Sonia is constrained with
the current
um
consultation process and we will
potentially have recycling being added
to that list um so we do have to be
mindful of resourcing in the comms area
but I do think it is important that the
Resonance of Matilda get the facts to
their door
did you get that as a recommendation
there Susan that all makes sense yep
uh
cancel
just the financing of the 200 000k how
does that get financed on the annual
plan and who actually pays for the
demolition of the pool
thank you
so the recommendation is it stands is
that the council will figure that out as
part of its annual plan process
um and if it can't I guess it will roll
over to the to the ltp as we've done
with the waste minimalization officer of
noting it and then to have that
conversation
which which department pays and how's it
funded
three you worship I think the
the expectation from Council Phillips
when he made that point was that the
council should fund it therefore the
funding should come from greater than
just the Matera community and it should
be
probably somewhere on a district-wide
type facility funding funding facility
but there may there may be other
sources of funding that we can access
but we need some time to think about
that but in principle if there is going
to be
a rate component or a servicing of any
borrowing for that
it likely suggest it would be District
wide in some type of format
I think so
raising of the uniformed annual charge
through your worship I see it in some
type of format so it allows the elective
members to
um
determine what that format might be but
yes you're not actually hamstrung you
could have a uniform charge but everyone
pays equally towards a demolition
I I think it also is should be noted as
well
um to councilor Phillips point that the
money that has been put aside with the
better off funding that 500k is not to
be used towards the the demolition of
the building um that is for Telex State
Park stage two
councilor heister
I think that's a good intention but I
think if we're going for Community
funding for Community Trust in LT which
should be part of the partner in the
stage two funding the the total cost of
project assists
um funding arrangements so
just caution ourselves limiting the um
the size of the project by by putting
that in Council hands so know the intent
but I think
the bigger the project the more help
the community can give us Community
funders can give us
I think I was just relaying the point
that was heavily um
circulated at that that meeting where
they discussed it where they didn't want
any of the demolition paid for
um by that that fund but ultimately the
bigger the projects the bigger the
investment so that is untaken a book
any further discussion
do I have a mover for the motion
councilor Guardian secondary councilor
Stringer any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion has been carried
Point 13 proposed Grant subcommittee do
you want to speak to this one Steve
thanks worship
um we we have been the council in
previous committee and Council meetings
I believe uh just talked a bit about how
we police
grants and we have police slash
oversight of Grants and I may mention
that there was previously a grant
subcommittee that ran for about two
years and it was
the combined effect of the floods in
2020 followed by covid-19 and a
departure of a key staff member which
all contributed to that particular
subcommittee running out of juicer
weebit and didn't really
um Carry On but in the two years life it
had it proved to be very worthwhile albe
at that time there was a little bit of
misunderstanding some of the committee
members particularly then cheer thought
they needed to have a budget to work to
and and the the idea behind the grant
subcommittee was to be the first Port of
Call for the council in both assessing
the need for the retention of Grants and
also assessing the need for
making new grants to to organizations
that might might apply for Council
funding
so the intention is to reinstitute the
um sub Community Grant subcommittee and
you'll see the the terms of reference
have been largely been resurrected from
the past I would however just there's
one slight Amendment under the two
reference to
uh sorry 3D I refer to the finance and
policy committee it should be the
community wellbeing committee if you
could just make that Amendment
um but apart from that you worship it's
a it is a
a vehicle which has proved to be useful
in the past and I think we'll give
councilors a greater degree of
confidence that grants when they're
Advanced by the council there is a a
follow-up and then there is the the
comfort of knowing that the funds have
been used for the intended purpose and
also that the funds are still required
to be about to that particular
organization
yeah
thank you for that Stu do we have any
questions for Steve on
this report Council read
thank you Mr Mayor um
Steve are presuming that um the Chief
Financial Officer would be part of that
committee
not part of the committee uh dealership
but it would be the Principal advisor
yeah okay and and my other point is is
five councils too many is it top heavy
that is purely your choice a lot to me
okay
councilor Phillips
thank you worship
um he's a former member of this of the
grants committee um and I think Council
Nixon was will say that and John
uh I felt it quite um
uh good for the aspect of that when
submissions came forward
um
to put to the grants committee
um we learned quite a lot about
how the how the the people that came
forward with these submissions why they
wanted the money Etc and the reasoning
why and it gave us a really good insight
about how
we were utilizing the grants committee
money
and it was quite a substantial amount of
money that we're issuing out uh yearly
so
um and I think the the resurrection of
the subcommittee will will enhance a
council
and we don't necessarily need to issue
out every dollar that we have and um and
having submissions
prior to it made a huge difference in
five is a good number where it gave us
three then three councilors then
uh the ability to be able to have on
this submission panel when they came
forward
um they gave us a little bit of a leeway
to move this forward
um I think
the recommendations can can stand I
think the other the other recommendation
is that a
a report comes back to the next council
with the membership of who those
councils are so if this recommendation
goes through we will then collect up the
names who want to be on that grants
committee and if there's more than five
I'll sit down with councilor Dixon and
we can go through and see who might be
best to sit on that
and also a bit of a either a meeting
schedule or a work program for that
subcommittee so that's the members of of
that subcommittee understand what
they're getting themselves into
is it cancel over
I'm just wondering why we can't have
volunteers tonight and that we've got
um councilors gadine Phillips and Dixon
who have previously been on it that
seemingly suitable to continue on it and
if there are two other counselors
willing to put their hand up can't we
settle it tonight
foreign
just last time I tried that I got a bit
of pushback as to people not wanting to
put their their hands up in public forum
are we going to be able to settle on a
number of five or
I don't I don't know if people want to
councilor Phillips uh you worship thank
you yeah I'm more than willing to uh
once again participate in that um Grant
sweaty no problem at all and I think
that there was a new counselor willing
to stand up that would be a good
opportunity for them to learn
coat that's two
do we have three more
yeah I'll put my name on the head for
that
four
uh sorry who were so we had just for
clarification councilor Phillips we
counselor MacDonald
the accounts the Stringer we're
councilor McKenzie
and myself by virtue of the office
oh Council Dixon needs to be on that as
well are we are we happy with six
yep
I just thought it might be fitting
considering it's coming back to your
committee but you don't have to if you
don't want to
quite happy to sit on it
I'm just wondering about the process so
we had the subcommittee that comes to
the
well-being Commission sheep comes to
council
then
is that not a wee bit
yeah convoluted
it would it would be just like we did at
the start of this meeting we went
through minutes so you wouldn't need to
dig back into each of the grants
necessarily you can just ratify those
minutes of the
Community they can come straight back to
counselor if need be
sure you worship the it's consistent
with the council's previous articulated
view that it wanted to see subcommittees
work through standing committees and not
report directly to council to keep
Council free
Council Phillips thank you and that's
how it worked last time it worked very
well
um all it was was the the list of Grants
came to us we decided uh the schedule uh
we put out then submissions to the
um persons putting wanting money to
council we went through the list
um set dates times Etc all that set set
with them then pass on their
recommendation to the committee and then
they would look at it and forwarded it
back to the council
that fills me with comfort so
um I will table the recommendation that
the council approved the establishment
or the grant subcommittee that the
attached terms of reference with any
agreement amendments are here to are
approved and that the council appoint
the six council's names did you get all
of those Susan yep
um to the grants subcommittee could I
please have a or is there any further
discussion
could I ever move that motion
councilor Stringer I will put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
establishment of the district plan
subcommittee to the activity if you want
to speak to this one at all
pretty straightforward you worship it's
just that uh it hasn't ever been
formally uh constituted by the council
and we could have a terms of reference
but this this particular subcommittee
will have a relatively short shelf life
because as soon as the district planned
is notified there will be a hearings
panel which will will be different to
make up to take up the district plan
review process from there on in
thank you Steve do we have any further
comment on that item
no I will put the recommendation that
the district plan subcommittee be
formally established to oversee the
completion of the review and expected
public notification in July 2023 of the
gore District plan noting the elected
members already appointed co-opius of a
mover for that motion councilor Stringer
and a seconder councilor mcdonell I will
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
and against the motion is carried
minutes from the matoda community board
did we have any questions of the
governance manager or Nikki who is in
attendance
so just so councils are aware this will
exclude items
three as we've already gone through that
are gender item
the only part I would draw the council's
attention to is around the truck parking
um and the board confinement would not
be responsible for providing truck
parking on public land and the board
requests at the council to include a
provision in the roading bylaw currently
being reviewed prohibiting overnight
parking of trucks at Costa Park
and on residential streets of Matilda
did we have an
is there any concerns with that or are
we all happy uh councilor Stringer
um just yeah how are we going to enforce
that and what to enforce it worse and
yeah
the roading bylaw
yeah yeah but
um who is it like yes it'll be me as a
bylaw but who is actually going to be
physically on the ground knocking on
those trucks when they lock them up at
night do they go in and put a clamp on
the truck
um you think we should look at the
bylaws uh if legally made are
enforceable and so if there is a
flagrant breach
um The Local Government Act provides
some pretty stiff fines payable for
example by
the company concerned if there was but
you do that after you you warned them
and said please don't do it so
um
material is a small community I would
think that someone that flagrantly
breaches a well-publicized bylaw would
bring it to the attention of the council
and then we would have to take
regulatory action which prosecution is
the absolute Last Resort but believe me
a breach of a bylaw lawfully made does
attract some very steep penalties and
can be exacerbated by being fined on a
daily basis
Council hosted
so just further to that this prohibition
of parking on residential streets is
that consistent with other areas like
Angora
I know and in material I know there are
there are trucks packing on residential
streets as long as they're courteous to
the neighbors they seem to be okay I'm
just thinking in a small community like
my tower if you can't park in
residential streets and you're a Truckee
um we depak so interesting some comment
around the context of that intent
but sorry I'll just jump in there it was
it's a shame that Murray's not here
um but it was brought up in the meeting
as well it's around the the trucks at a
park and residential areas the roads
aren't built for that um so they sit on
the roads and ultimately damage our
roads over time because you've got heavy
Vehicles sitting on them so that's the
main reason for for wanting to get off
the presidential streets
thanks for that in terms of the context
of this across
places like Gore
towns what is the what is the general
approach
through worship I uh my Murray
impression would be that having
with with him having worked in other
areas in scene uh the likes of the stuff
happened before that this is not
isolated to
um just south and I went to gore
district and so
um this is
the practice that's undertaken in other
areas to
um reduce I guess some of the effects
associated with
um trucks parking in residue areas such
as starting up at uh four or five
o'clock in the morning to kick off so
there is some
um precedent for this from other areas
but there's also a process to go through
which we would engage through publicly
and receive feedback and all those sorts
of things and further to the chief
executive's point that around the uh any
prohibition we certainly would be
engaging directly with the truck
companies involved in ensuring that
they're well aware of any change to
rules through that process
foreign
I guess it just and this probably go
without saying but just a I guess a note
um that when we do come to that that
writing by law discussion that there are
some evidence of President
um displayed so that we can make an
informed decision on that one
um the other points um I'd like to bring
Council attention to is just around uh
the motion that the concept plan
um drafted by one of the community board
members
um to be explored for for cost
estimating that there's no issues there
as well
so this is just a concept plan um it
would be mean that staff would go out
and seek how much that they cost
which obviously comes at a cost small
one but
no complaints it's perfect
uh could I please oh cancel thoughts uh
thank you where is it um just just one
thing about the the vandalism uh that's
been occurring in material
um I've been speaking with the local
policeman Malachi in
um
his first name the other policeman
um they have at a we have a small group
of youths numbering between
five and sometimes up to eight nine of
them wandering the street they are
frequent users of tullock Park
and yeah there are they have been spoken
to a couple of them who are have been
arrested for other offenses
the group has been broken up and aspect
is that if they are seen together they
will be dealt with even further so the
local policeman has been disappointed
with the amount of cost or the vandalism
that was occurred in not only the board
so
you know hopefully we're dealing with it
um and we can move on
hopefully with the with a small group
I think I think the biggest thing that
we need to do probably in the future is
get them together
and just reinforce that if they keep
vandalizing and they won't get what they
want and you know and they know that
they want stage two up and running in
the full court
um at telek Park but if they keep
vandalizing it they won't get it and I
think um I think it has been reinforced
by the two policemen to this group and
hopefully we'll see a deliciation in the
in the vandalism in the terror
thank you for that counselor uh
councilor Stringer
uh through his worship to council
Phillips
um are there cameras
around the park there I understand there
are Council cameras in the terror
there's actually probably more cameras
and material than what there is in Gore
actually
but um yeah there's a couple of cameras
and that's been one of our discussions
um through the Geo Nikki and one of our
discussions about upgrading our cameras
and
um we'll approach bringing forward in a
long-term plan about cameras and stuff
like that on the fourth there'll be one
of our discussions we'll just be
cautious on camera conversations I know
I've got a little bit out of hand at the
the community award meeting
um so yeah we can possibly touch on that
a little bit in committee as well if to
help cancel string around
Council has said
you just a glitch on quick one on page
163 um Clause eight it's just referring
to the cleaning of the the bridge and I
just note that the board's offered to
assist with some co-funding to to
encourage nzta
um just interested in that concept where
we pay significant road taxes and Road
user charges and and have been taxed
once and then text again as a community
to clean the bridge is there any way we
can put pressure on this
organization
rather than paying for the cleaning and
what what extent are we talking about a
minor sum or can someone inform me how
much security would have committed to um
to cleaning that bridge
so preceding conversations that we had
with ncta around the the pipeline we did
talk about uh the cleaning of their
assets and as you rightly stated they're
not our assets so why should we have to
clean them but they are a state for our
community to look at nzta see that they
are funded for for safety and qualities
they're not not funded for amenities and
cleaning
um so they were they were pretty hard on
that point however the community board
did have a conversation at the meeting
prior to that around potentially funding
it themselves through the purification
fund or or kind of half funding it so we
we vocalize that with katahi
um who then came to us and said you
would be one of the very few councils
who were willing to meet us halfway and
we could definitely have that
conversation about them paying for half
and us paying for us so in terms of
putting the hammer down with them half
as as for them in their eyes kind of
coming to the table and that that is the
pressure does that cover rightly based
on a conversation yeah hopefully
I I don't know I don't know what the
costing is I believe that the community
award is seeking out what it would cost
for a partial clean and a full clean I
think that was I think we accepted that
in the minutes last time Jason did you
have a comment
uh only minor one from that meeting with
uh you understand James Cagle was going
to come back to
yourself being on
um what that that may look like
um we're also just to confirm that
um Murray has suggested two through the
community board that there's an
opportunity to invite local
representatives from Waka kotahi down
and maybe have some discussions at a
local level two about whether or not
there's opportunities to improve the uh
the state of the infrastructure there
yeah I think that Jason I think also
another another point was right so
they're amazing is that things like the
intersection which we're also talking to
them about they were basically saying if
they have contractors on site already
putting out the safety gear then
cleaning their assets can be added into
the the scope because they're already
there already servicing something it's
not that much more
um to pair contact to to clean graffiti
or whatever or clean moss so they're
also open to that we just need to know
when they're there for work and seduce
it to them because I read
thank you Mr Mia um just sorry but just
back to telek park it did occur to me to
ask
is the vandalism happening at night or
through the day is there any idea Nikki
as to when that vandalism is taking
place
no well because my next point was if it
was mainly a nighttime thing under cover
of Darkness that the gore Community
Patrol that you know do our streets many
years ago used to go to Matera as well I
don't know whether they currently do or
not but it might be worth a flea in the
area and ask them if they'd just pop
down on the odd occasion have a wee
cruise around
it's just a present sometimes
thank you councilor anyone comment on
the minutes from the matoto community
board
uh councilor Phillips I think it was I
just like to uh
say that I think
the material community board while
they've got good intentions about having
the pay should not have to pay and
that's my own personal view on this SBT
is
uh um once again throwing away throwing
away a situation and I believe that what
they should be doing is they should be
having a feel-good situation saying yes
um look we like to look after this
community and yes we will
um clean up your bridge at our cost and
I don't believe that we should be paying
anything for it because that's what we
pay at Road Texas for is Council house
did to said uh and while we pay it's
driving at Cost rear fuel
yeah I've a tend to agree but that was
the feedback back from wakatahi so while
we will continue to have that
conversation when we meet with them
um yeah the only thing I guess we can do
is
put pressure on on wakatahi and where we
can see yeah yeah
uh could I please have a move that these
minutes be received and the
recommendations bar 0.3
uh which is the pool one yep
um uh ratified
uh councilor Phillips seconded by
councilor Paul mcphail all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh staff issuing of warrants uh
did we have any comment from some stuff
straightforward on this one do we have
any comment from councilors councilor
Reed happy to move the recommendation
secondary counselor Richard mcfail
um any conversation
no I would put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh minutes from the creative communities
assessments uh did either of the
attendees want to comment on those
moments uh Council Dixon
I'd just like to say then um there needs
to be a correction
um the bottom line the full amount
um
for uh for the funding was 14 557.09
so this conflicting figures here
that's been part of the recommendation
It should read um fourteen thousand five
fifty Seven
that's what the figures add up to
thank you councilor
any other questions or queries from
the risk Council
nope I could obviously remember that
those minutes are received
uh councilor Reed
um and a second to councilor heisted
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye and against the motion is
carried
uh so somebody from mural Forum it's
pretty straightforward
um this month
um
did we have any questions of myself
regarding these minutes
the only only part I would comment on
um
as around the representation for the new
Dean hospital local Advisory Group
the individual that Tracy had appointed
or the the uh previous mail from had
appointed was a Gore representative she
didn't feel that she was at the the
governance level to handle those
conversations so asked that she she'd be
stepped back from that which was
respected and invercargill city has a
counselor who has a background in health
so they have volunteered for that to be
part of that meeting
oh and that was pretty straightforward
could I please have a move that
information be received uh councilor
Reed seconded by Council Stringer all
those in favor please say aye and
against the motion is carried
I might I think we'll have a break here
before we exclude the public but we will
go straight into excluded public
afterwards or did people just want to
push on
just push on
oh that's in committee yeah yeah
do we want to push on or people want a
bit of a break push on
coat
uh so I will move that the public be
excluded from the following parts of the
proceedings meeting namely the items
listed below
which is the